we now have more uh founding era
documents from 1770
about 1770 to 1830
than anybody but the library of congress
and the national archives
we just bought a massive collection
uh that i mean the smithsonian was in
the running
i mean it's massive
that is all of the pilgrim history
and all of the history of jamestown and
everything so we have
the largest collection and we intend on
putting 1619
uh in its place because that is an
absolute lie and there's something to
say
when you go that's not true oh well who
are you well
just the one that has all of the
documents in their own handwriting to
say what happened
because you're a collector you have tons
of stuff i mean when you
you've got darth vader's helmet you've
got dorothy's ruby red slippers you got
the golden ticket
willy wonka's golden ticket but you also
have some incredible
stuff and you're building a museum right
now dedicated to
really the history of america yeah and
the stuff that you talk about all the
time it's both the good
and the bad my partner in this project
is david barton
and he's been collecting all the good
things about america
and my daughter uh she wanted to go to
school and
and uh they both hated history but
they would come home and i'd say what
are you learning about history and then
i would tell them the story
and so they both both my older daughters
majored in history
and uh and ended up loving it but my
daughter came to home and she said
dad i'm gonna i'm gonna major in history
and i said great
and i said we need great american
historians and she said
uh you know dad your view of america is
just so
utopian and you know it's red white and
blue and apple pie
which wasn't exactly true but kind of
and uh she said uh it's just too ugly
it's really an ugly history and i'm
thinking
if my child is saying that in my home
what kind of nonsense has been filled in
and i said
i said i tell you what first of all what
are you taking she said
greek in roman history and i said oh
well that's completely bloodless
yeah you're good to go no problems there
and uh i said here's the deal
that's cool but i will read all the dark
things about history you have to read
and research some of the good things
because it's like winston churchill you
read about him in europe
he's a great guy you read about him from
the indian perspective
he's a freaking nightmare and it really
bothered me when i looked at both sides
i'm a huge fan of winston churchill
who's that guy the answer is he's both
of
the same okay he's both of them history
is about a
trajectory are you getting better or are
you getting worse
like our constitution says a more
perfect nation
not a perfect nation we should be
striving to be more perfect every day
so uh so i started collecting all of the
really dark things
we now have guillotines from the french
revolution we have uh
that was an odd way for me to show up in
texas yeah and you bring me immediately
into the room and here's the guillotine
and the electric chair yeah we have the
first or second electric chair ever made
it was used in the new york penitentiary
and i i have that because
i hate edison i hate him he was a
bad dude and the electric chair
was all about just getting people to get
away
from tesla's dc power or ac power so
when you say he was a bad dude you're
talking about the
what he did to tesla and just the
business type of things that he did
he controlled everybody yeah our history
is just not told right so
i started collecting these things we now
have more
uh founding era documents from 1770
about 1770 to 1830
than anybody but the library of congress
and the national archives
we just bought a massive collection
uh that i mean the smithsonian was in
the running and
i mean it's massive uh that is all of
the
pilgrim history and all of the history
of jamestown and everything so we have
the largest collection and we intend on
putting 1619
in its place because that is an absolute
lie and there's something to say
when you go that's not true oh well who
are you well uh just the one that has
all of the documents in their own
handwriting to say what happened
yeah well you've been ahead of the curve
on on a couple things over the years and
i suspect that this is going to be
another one of those times
because people are ready people people
you know there was the pushback against
1619 it took a while
but there was a pushback and then they
started slowly retracting some of it and
deleting tweets and things like that
but the next piece is actually giving
the counter narrative and having the
real breadth of work behind it right
it doesn't matter don't don't take it
from me
look at the original documents we're
going to start a class
uh online it'll be free and uh you can
either do it in person here or you can
take it online
uh and it is the truth about our
founders
and our nation who are we what did we
let me show you yeah so you you brought
a ton of stuff here i don't even know
what you have here we're doing this on
the fly
yeah so this is something nobody ever
sees
this is the engraving of the first draft
of the declaration of independence in
thomas jefferson's handwriting
it's four pages as you the other two
pages unbelievable
all right notice on the sides you'll see
on the margins
if you've ever used microsoft documents
and you've made a change
it always puts off to the side who made
the change what the change was and date
right here oh my god it's in their
handwriting
when they change something they crossed
it out and then they put on the margin
b franklin j adams and what they changed
in the date is that not crazy
god it's like wait so i asked you this
yesterday but can you just explain
people how
first i think it's hard for people to
understand that these things still exist
right i think that's one thing but how
do you how do you possibly
attain these things like how does this
come to be
some of these things have been donated
to us
for preservation and because they don't
want them in
public hands they don't want them held
by the government they don't want them
held in universities because we
want them to always be on display
always to be available online so you can
go use it as an original source we're
currently taking all the documents we
have and digitizing them
so it's not just a big book or you know
something online that
says what it it shows you in their own
handwriting
you know it's incredible when you look
at this and you think about all the all
the bills that are passed now
and you see the you know the stacks of
paper that you know nobody's read and
it's like
most important document in the world
four pages
four pages okay so the declaration is
first a dear john letter
the first part yeah except it's dear
george it's not us
it's you yeah uh and and it's because
you don't understand us
this is who we are and then it goes into
the second section which is the
usurpation
these are all the things that you've
done to us okay
if you get to page three
and this turns everything around on its
head
and this is available you could find
this document online
um people always say
and i have too how did thomas jefferson
say all men are created equal
and not know what he was saying well
then i've always had to go to well it
was a different time
he did struggle he he couldn't give his
slaves away because he was in debt
blah blah blah blah but that's not a
good answer
it's not a good answer this is
this in his own handwriting every
usurpation from page two to page four
is about one to two lines okay
this usurpation goes from here that is a
that's a whole paragraph
and if you look at it his handwriting
changes
and he said um
that this king has um
has waged cruel war against human nature
itself violating its most sacred right
of life and liberty in the persons
of a distant people who were who never
offended him
captivating them and carrying them into
slavery in another hemisphere
to incur miserable death in their
transportation
this uh warfare on humans the aprobium
of
infidel powers is the warfare and then
it's
capitalized christian and underlined
the christian king of great britain
determined to keep an
open market where capital letters the
only thing capitalized in this
document are the words united states of
america at the very heading
he capitalizes where he has on an open
market
men should be bought and sold
he is saying the
african-american is not a slave
he's a man now he goes on to say
we've been fighting him he blocks us
every turn
we've tried to get rid of this poison
but we can't
he keeps blocking us now he's telling
the slaves you can gain your freedom if
you kill
us and we're trying to free him so he's
he's
doubly injuring these people it's an
amazing paragraph
so why isn't it in the declaration of
independence
because john hancock stood up before
they selected even who would write
the declaration they stood up and said
okay
we know if we aren't all 100 percent in
lockstep
the king is going to say virginia you
know what you don't agree with him
and he'll divide us we cannot be divided
who here says we have to be unanimous
before this was written
all states said unanimous that's why the
finnish draft says the unanimous
declaration
of the united states of america
declaration of independence
he brought this back every word every
line had to be voted on
when they got to that out of the 13
colonies
two two said no that leaves
11 colonies and importantly
virginia which is a southern colony
george washington thomas jefferson all
of the big names are in virginia
they said yes to that paragraph only two
colonies said no so
help me out how are all of our founders
racist dirt dirt bags didn't know what
slavery was
they clearly did if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of nonstop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell